yeah liz trust confirmed as foreign  section as sam was saying uh she knows  everyone because she's been doing these  trade deals she is the most popular  woman well  politician uh for the conservative party  members and there has been a view within  government that she's worked really hard  she's done really well and she's been  rewarded with this big office of state  you remember she wanted to run as leader  do you remember that yeah but she  couldn't she didn't have the same yeah  she couldn't do it she fell behind but  she has with international trade she's  been involved in this area of dealing  with other countries yeah so so it all  ties in doesn't it you know global  britain  uh diplomacy but also with a big you  know a big chunk of trade and commercial  mouse which they want to inject into  that the pm has decided that she's the  right woman for that brief